TODAY'S ARREST AND THE
FALLOUT FROM THAT.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE WITH A
LOOK AT HOW INVESTIGATORS
GOT THEIR SUSPECT.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THANK YOU, BRET AND GOOD
EVENING.
TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS THE
CULMINATION OF A FIVE DAY
MANHUNT THAT BEGAN MONDAY IN
THE GREATER NEW YORK AREA
AND ENDED A THOUSAND MILES
AWAY IN SOUTH FLORIDA
DRAWING ON MORE THAN A DOZEN
FEDERAL AGENCIES LED BY THE
SECRET SERVICE AND FBI.
>> WE HAVE ARRESTED CESAR
SAYOC IN CONNECTION WITH
WITH THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> THE 56-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT
WAS ARRESTED IN SOUTH
FLORIDA AND IS NOW FACING
FIVE FEDERAL CRIMINAL COUNTS
FOR SENDING EXPLOSIVES
THROUGH THE MAIL AND
TARGETING CURRENT AND FORMER
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS.
>> THIS IS UTTERLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
POLITICAL VIOLENCE OR THE
THREAT OF VIOLENCE IS
ANESTHETIC CALL TO OUR
VIGOROUS SYSTEM OF
SELF-GOVERNMENT.
>> FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
SEIZED HIS VAN COVERING IT
WITH A BLUE TARP CONCEALING
PRO-TRUMP STICKERS.
PRAISING REPUBLICANS,
SLAMMING DEMOCRATS.
AND SHOWCASING VIDEOS OF
HIMSELF APPEARS AT TRUMP
RALLIES.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
PRESSED WHY SAYOC SINGLED
OUT DEMOCRATS AND ONE
POWERFUL PARTY DONOR.
>> HE APPEARS TO BE A
PARTISAN.
BUT THAT WOULD BE DETERMINED
BY THE FACTS.
>> THE BREAK IN THE CASE
CAME WHEN FBI LAB IDENTIFIED
A LATENT FINGERPRINT ON ONE
OF THE SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE
ENVELOPES ADDRESSED TO
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
MAXINE WATERS.
TWO ADDITIONAL PIECES OF
D.N.A. EVIDENCE FROM OTHER
PACKAGES MATCHED SAYOC
ALREADY IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DATABASE BECAUSE
OF HIS PAST CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
>> THE WORK OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
HERE AND THE WORK THAT WAS
DONE OVER THE LAST WEEK IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD MAKE
EVERY AMERICAN PROUD AND
GRATEFUL.
>> ANOTHER DEVICE WAS
DISCOVERED TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA ADDRESSED TO
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR KAMALA
HARRIS.
AND IN NEW YORK CITY
ADDRESSED TO CNN CONTRIBUTOR
AND FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE JAMES
CLAPPER.
THE FBI DIRECTOR EMPHASIZED
THE DEVICES, NOW MORE THAN A
DOZEN, INTERCEPTED ON THE
EAST AND WEST COAST WERE
DANGEROUS, NOT A HOAX.
LAYING OUT NEW DETAILS OF
THEIR CONSTRUCTION.
>> EACH DEVICE CONSISTED OF
ROUGHLY SIX INCHES OF PVC
PIPE, A SMALL CLOCK, A
BATTERY, SOME WIRING AND
WHAT IS KNOWN AS ENERGETIC
MATERIAL.
>> A CONVICTION ON THE FIVE
FEDERAL CRIMINAL CHARGES
WHICH COULD EXPAND AS THE
INVESTIGATION PROGRESSES
CARRY THE PRISON TERM OF UP
TO 48 YEARS.
>> THE DEFENDANT'S CONDUCT
AS CHARGED IS COWARDLY AND
REPREHENSIBLE AND TOTALLY
ANATHEMA TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> IN THE LAST FEW MINUTES
WE LEARNED THAT SAYOC WILL
HAVE FIRST COURT APPEARANCE
ON MONDAY.
TOLD FOX AFTER THAT INITIAL
COURT APPEARANCE IN MIAMI
SAYOC IS EXPECTED TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO NEW YORK CITY
AND PROSECUTED THERE.
NEARLY HALF OF THE PACKAGES
WERE ROUTED THROUGH THE
GREATER NEW YORK CITY AREA,
BRET.
>> Bret: CATHERINE, THE NEWS
CONFERENCE WAS PRETTY DO
TAILED.
THEY SAID THEY WERE STILL
INVESTIGATING WHETHER HE HAD
ANY HELP WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
WHAT ELSE WAS KIND OF LEFT
OUT OF THAT.
>> NEVER REALLY GOT TO THE
ISSUE OF PREMEDITATION.
WAS THIS SOMETHING HE DID
OVER SEVERAL WEEKS HIMSELF?
SO MAKING HIM A LONE ACTOR
IN THIS OFFICE OR WAS IT
DONE VERY QUICKLY WHICH